[Music]
bum
bump
[Music]
[Music]
my name is ali dowa
well that's not my real name but that's
what people call me
i'm 32 years old
i've got two kids
a family
i'm a grown man i'm six foot two
something along those lines medium built
can be scary and i'm joking the point
i'm doing this video about my sister is
because i'm riding the scooter but
before i
did
i had to call
[Applause]
um
foreign
now the question that a lot of people
maybe non-muslims maybe they will not
understand or grasp
is why would a grown man who's got kids
call his mom to ask for a permission to
ride the scooter now i'm not doing this
to see pirates yeah i have my short
comments when it comes to my mom
sometimes
back remember before i came to islam i
was disobedient and i listened to my mom
i would even raise my voice up my mom
now some people say you don't need to be
religious to be a good person i totally
disagree because the last night that i
came from before all my friends used to
disobey their parents they didn't give a
damn about their parents what lies you
know people who would hit them hit their
parents insult their parents
so when people come and say to me you
don't need religion to be a good person
i totally disagree because the customs
of the lifestyle that will live
culturally yeah um can change you and
can cause you to disrespect your parents
so much so there are people who are
leaving their family their mom and dad
in care homes the prophet muslim said
may his face be rubbed on dust may his
face be rubbed on dust
may his face be rubbed on dust for the
one whose parents reach old age and they
don't take care of them this is a
reminder to myself first and you guys
the point i'm trying to make here is
this the reason i call my mom's ask for
permission is because she said to me ali
it's dangerous i care about you i don't
want you to ride them so i was just
about to get on to this because we did
some
filming here
i said oh i just remembered it my phone
said what happened my friend is that
what's going on the brother is recording
this may allah bless him so he i was
like bro i just remembered you know what
my mom said i'm not allowed to ride this
so i rang him obviously a little bit
smirk in his face but then he was like
you know what it's true i remember i
said mom
i need to go from atv it's a bit far
okay i said can i write it and she said
yes
just this time et cetera yeah the point
i'm trying to make is this i'm proud of
this i'm not ashamed of this if my mom
and like i look up the khabib
the same his mom said to him no more ufc
the guy is 29
he wouldn't want to make that maybe 30.
my mom said that it's not happening this
is how we need to honor our parents
that's what allah says in the quran
after i tell you to obey me and worship
me be obedient to your parents even if
they are disbelievers be gentle with
them and if you're going to disagree in
good terms that's all i wanted to say
brother and sister it's a little subtle
reminder but wallahi this is reminder to
me myself first i'm not trying to have a
high horse i'm better trust me i still
have shortcomings but the point i'm
trying to make is be obedient to your
parents there are people who regret it
their parents have died and they're like
oh i wish i could do this it's too late
it's too late just as death reaches you
there's no when i go back i'm gonna do
this honor your parents they are your
daughter jannah if you disobey them
wallahi do not ever expect any good in
life that's all i can say to you guys
inshallah
i'm going to go and hopefully you can
take these guys on board if your parents
have passed away the prophet peace be
upon him said there's three things
sadaqa
making dua and visiting their friends
may allah bless you guys inshallah
i'm off